mesdames et messieurs bonsoir les
informations que nous développerons dans
cette édition ont trait en premier lieu
à une interview du président carter sur
les rapports etats unis europe
occidentale à propos de l'iran et du
boycott des jeux de moscou décidé hier
soir par le comité olympique américain
ensuite la situation à cuba où l'on
apprend que les premiers candidats au
départ pourrait prendre l'avion après
demain pour le pérou en politique
intérieure réception chaleureuse et des
socialistes monsieur mitterrand à
boulogne-sur-mer et monsieur le kent et
lui était l'invité du club de la presse
à europe numéro un pour les millions de
turfiste résultats du tiercé haas 7 15
quant à paris roubaix la course a été
enlevé pour la troisième fois par
moselle mais nous commencerons par ce
que j'appellerais l'application pratique
du beau temps il fait très beau le temps
et même chaud pour un mois d'avril
des millions de français en ont profité
pour s'adonner à l'un des grands sports
nationaux du pays
le jardinage il ya 200 ans candide
donnait déjà ce grand conseil depuis
lozeau fille et de bonheur sur terre
cultivons notre jardin gérard welmant
contrairement à ce que dit la rumeur
la saison n'est pas en retard les
forsythia ou des jaunes à point et les
cerisiers sont parfois déjà blond mais
si la nature n'attend pas le soleil pour
agir les hommes si ce week-end c'était
donc la ruée vers les surfaces
spécialisées premier conseil ne plantez
pas d'arbres fruitiers maintenant mais
les conifères prennent très bien la
terre étant suffisamment réchauffé pour
les riffs lors c'est la pleine saison de
la plantation des plantes vivaces en
jardin sans jardin c'est à dire toutes
les plantes qui dure plusieurs années en
place et qui refleurissent tous les ans
la même époque soit au printemps ce
qu'on est et selon tan est actuellement
vous avez par exemple toutes les plantes
à floraison printanière de rocaille les
deux bordures les eaux brillent et sia
les avis et c'est qu'ils sont en fleurs
que les clients peuvent voir sur place
beyer également toutes les plantes qui
fleurissent en été
l'automne et qui sont livrés
actuellement en départ de végétation
jeunes plants et qu'on peut mettre en
place pour plusieurs avec longtemps les
jardiniers amateurs ont dédaigné le
potager aujourd'hui les doigts verts
s'intéressent à tout ce qui pousse dont
les légumes
or en avril tout est à faire ou à
préparer actuellement implantée vous
avez toutes les salades vous avez des
choses le chou-fleur les céleris que ce
qu'on peut semer ya des quantités de
choses à semer alors directement en
france par exemple les carottes les
navets cetera qui vont se développer à
partir de graines de la phase aucune
espèce de difficulté
il est encore un peu tôt pour porter des
choses délicates des choses qui
craignent la g comme les tomates les
aubergines les poivrons qui risquent de
geler si elles sont plantées trop tôt
par contre on peut acheter dès
maintenant des plants de tomates par
exemple les mettre sous un châssis on
les cultive en pot pour leur faire
prendre de l'avancé les plantes est
définitivement femme et quand il n'y
aura plus de risques de jane balcons et
terrasses c'est aussi la bonne époque
si votre fenêtre est ensoleillée du
géranium en toutes orientées nord d
impatience par exemple
quant à l'envi de récolter persie radis
salades ou bien tomates sur votre balcon
elle est tout à fait réalisable car il
ya des espèces étudiées poux évidemment
l'idéal c'est d'avoir de la pleine terre
pour laisser libre plates-bandes à sa
passion exemple certains comédiens comme
marina vlady qui tient essentiellement à
son jardin dont les bourgeons sont
encore un peu frileux
jardine un petit peu je plante des
tomates je plante de la salade des zergs
enfin la ciboulette du ster fait mais
j'ai surtout planté beaucoup d'armes
dans cette propriété avec ma mère vous
avez là trois boulots qui sont très très
bon boulot qui me font penser à la régie
et puis là ce sont les boulons rouge
et bien c'est un boulot qui est un
signal rouge et intro un peu rose il ya
tous les sapins qui sont derrière cet
on les a pas que j'ai ramené d'un peu
partout dans le monde journées ramené
d'italie de russie
c'est merveilleux de la pousser les
arbres ça dernier muscles de sérénité et
jouent trop le président jimmy carter a
obtenu hier soir ce qu'il voulait en ce
qui concerne des jeux olympiques à une
très grande majorité des deux tiers des
voix à peu près le comité olympique
américain a suivi les recommandations
pressantes de la maison blanche et il a
décidé qu'aucun athlète des états unis
mirettes à moscou sauf si d'ici le 20
mai des soviétiques changer d'attitude
en afghanistan mais par ailleurs le
président carter n'est pas encore obtenu
des alliés occidentaux
l'aide qu'il espèrait d'eux dans la
sphère des otages il veut que les
européens prennent comme les états unis
des mesures strictes contre l'iran si
des otages ne sont pas libérés voici un
extrait de ce qu'a dit le président
américain
ou correspondante plusieurs télévisions
d'europe occidentale ainsi il
s'adressait d'intello cette fois
beaucoup plus à l'opinion européenne
qu'à ses propres concitoyens
oui donnez tous ces corps
le président mr power et des dates
uniques smooth would be métairie bête et
de militance take action et gagnera
stage physique à l'action iberia a
exhorté le président des états unis
continue donc de reprocher à ses alliés
leur manque de solidarité aussi bien sur
le problème des jeux olympiques que dans
la série rania mais il reconnaît
publiquement que certains pays européens
ont servi d'intermédiaire pour obtenir
la libération des otages
cependant pour la première fois
également le président américain menacé
partenaires en affirmant qu'il aura fixé
une date précise
pour qu'un effort commun et concertée
soit menée sur le gouvernement iranien
enfin le président américain envisage
très clairement et c'est nouveau une
action militaire directe pour libérer
les otages
en fait jimmy cartierre t à peu près le
langage suivant européen messieurs dit
il si nous étions amenés à tenter un
coup de force en iran
ne vous leurrez pas les conséquences
seront aussi dramatique pour vous que
pour nous mais pour l'instant les
gouvernements européens comme une bonne
partie de l'opinion américaine affirme
que jimmy carter a réagi trop peu et
surtout trop tard ajoutez à cela que
depuis longtemps les hésitations et les
contradictions de l'exécutif américain
n'engage pas les alliés à s'aligner les
yeux fermés sur washington
plus les jours passent plus la position
du candidat et du président jimmy carter
de viata tenable même s'il durci le ton
en adressant une sorte d'ultimatum à
peine voilée aux européens
on sait parfaitement à la maison blanche
qu'il n'existe pratiquement plus de
moyens de pressions directes sur lyon
reste à savoir maintenant quand et
surtout si le président carter décidera
une intervention militaire en iran c'est
dans ce dilemme que le président
américain est actuellement enfermé et
qu'ils essaient d'en fermer ses alliés
en les rendant d'ores et déjà
responsable en partie d'une telle
décision alors je reviens sur les
réactions à propos du boycott des jeux à
moscou ville organisatrice on insiste
surtout sur les protestations de la part
de sportifs américains déçus et on
accuse violemment monsieur carter d'être
en proie à une démangeaison
antisoviétique un surpoids insupportable
allemagne de l'ouest monsieur schmitt a
dit avec les soviétiques en afghanistan
les conditions pour une présence des
sportifs est-allemands à moscou ne sont
pas remplies et il reste peu de temps à
l'urss pour faire qu'elle le soit grande
bretagne nous comprenons le secrétaire
du comité olympique mais ça ne changera
pas notre position d'envoyer des apps
est à moscou selon les intérêts
britanniques france madame brigitte
dumont vice présidente du comité
olympique français
la position française en faveur de la
participation au jeu ne changera sans
doute pas mais maurice herzog l'un des
deux membres français du comité
olympique international ceux des plus
pessimistes ils allemagne fédéral
renonce elle aussi au jeu la position
française
deviendrait très délicate je suis en
faveur dès jeudi l'ancien ministre
mais s'il n'y a que les pays socialistes
eh bien je ne vois pas l'intérêt de la
france
diané de son côté le mouvement de la
jeunesse communiste veut faire de la
fête d'avant garde les 7 et 8 juin à
saint denis un temps fort de soutien aux
jeux olympiques et pour monsieur pierre
zarka son secrétaire général monsieur
carter malgré l'ampleur de ses moyens
subi échec sur échec dans sa tentative
de dicter sa loi aux sportifs du monde
mais quelles sont les réactions aux
états unis même c'est ce que nous dit
jacques 6 contre l'amérique
la première de 84 à cuba les candidats à
la fuite continue à s'agglutiner dans
l'enceinte de l'ambassade du pérou après
demain mardi un premier contingent de
280 cubain doit quitter la havane pour
lima la capitale péruvienne où l'on
aménage un espace de 24 hectares
jusqu'ici parc de divertissement
pourrait accueillir provisoirement des
réfugiés comment se présentent les
choses à la havane une correspondance de
notre envoyé spécial à cuba
bernard a présenté ses dernières heures
par groupes de deux ou de trois à
l'extérieur du périmètre de l'ambassade
ou des bureaux avait été dressé à cet
effet
reste maintenant à organiser le départ
de des hommes que des femmes et des
enfants sur ce point et d'autorité
cubaine semble décidé à ne pas
d'autoriser un départ massif
le prg est au départ une goutte
en attendant quand la havane déserté ce
dimanche
on peut toujours voir des groupes de
manifestants dans les rues jean chavot
serralta le dernier français détenus en
uruguay vient d'être libéré il est
arrivé cet après midi à paris où il a
été accueilli par sa famille jan charouz
et râle pas avait été arrêté en juillet
72 pour des motifs politiques puis
torturés et incarcérés à la prison de
liberta sa libération est intervenue
après des années de démarches tant du
quai d'orsay que le comité privé
cet après midi en arrivant à paris il
avait de la peine à s'exprimer ce qui
n'étonnera évidemment personne
je suis très fatigué mes propos rien
alors
attendre vous parliez de vous parler des
contenus web détention par des tortures
morales
il reste actuellement trois français en
prison argentine ainsi que 14 personnes
disparues également son adjointe
le président du venezuela mais ce luis
ferreira campins quitté caracas à
destination de paris pour une visite
officielle de trois jours en france
le président vénézuélien à doite arrivée
dans la capitale demain en fin d'après
midi après une brève escale
hans van le monde troublé dans le monde
déchiré où nous vivons des états unis
restait petit de la première puissance
mondiale
peuvent-ils maintenir leur position
doit-il céder ou au contraire relever
les défis quels que soient les risques
voilà une série de graves questions à
laquelle très peu d'hommes peuvent
répondre l'un d'eux c'est l'ex président
richard nixon qui a mené le destin des
états unis pendant presque deux mandats
il publie un livre la vraie guerre chez
albin michel et il sera lundi prochain
c'est à dire le demain au but lundi
matin a dream
l'invité d'honneur d'antenne de mythes
france monsieur mitterrand était à
boulogne-sur-mer
l'invité de la fédération socialiste du
pas-de-calais qui avait reçu récemment
monsieur michel rocard et qui a réservé
aujourd'hui aux premiers secrétaires du
ps
un accueil très chaleureux un compte
rendu sur place par daniel brel
monsieur mitterrand a bien précisé qu'il
s'exprimait en tant que patron du parti
socialiste sous-entendu je ne suis en
concurrence avec personne il inciter
ceux qui l'écoutaient au recrutement et
au combat mais son discours ressemblait
tout de même beaucoup à celui d'un
possible candidat à l'elysée il a
dénoncé l'échec permanent du pouvoir un
million et demi de chômeurs 13 à 14 %
d'inflation 80,1 déficits budgétaires
suffisants pour mettre en oeuvre les
réformes du programme commun un franc
dévalué par rapport aux monnaies fort
que lui n'épargnent bafoués résultat un
pays
monrose ceci entraîne tant de malheurs
temps de 10
but étant de déception tant de promesses
menteuse s'entraîner d'abord un désarroi
un malaise un tout on n'y croit plus on
fera plus à la politique
on commence à ne plus croire au pays
on croit que c'est comme ça ça doit être
comme ça une sorte de nappe de
propagande s'abat sur les esprits toute
aide et autorise tout est magnifié au
gré de cette propagande on dissimule les
plaies c'est les malheurs et se
développe dans le même moment une
formidable immoralité public
et forcément les mêmes bars qui est
toujours au pouvoir vous sauver de la
frère d'un ministre il ya quelques
années c'était avant que monsieur
giscard d'estaing ne soit président de
la république d'un futur ministre de
l'époque mes copains et les coquins et
la saveur de cette citation appli à
distance ce sera de rappeler que l'odeur
de ce phrase c'était monsieur
poniatowski seul le parti socialiste
peut changer cet état de fait a affirmé
monsieur mitterrand absent du pouvoir
depuis longtemps il montre tous les
jours dans les municipalités et les
conseils généraux qu'il est capable de
gérer le pays
il n'est pas excessif de dire que le
parti socialiste peut espérer atteindre
ou dépasser 30% dans une élection
présidentielle ce qui le mettrait en
mesure de l'emporter au deuxième tour et
je suis de ceux qui croient que cette
élection est possible en dépit de tous
les diagnostics pronostics suppositions
sondage répondu la profusion pour tenter
de créer le trouble
monsieur giscard d'estaing mais pas du
tout assuré d'être réélu
surtout si de proche en proche il ya des
dimanches et lundis dès mardi et
mercredi les jeudi et vendredi saint
l dimanche de nouveau les salles comme
celle ci pour débattre pour discuter
pour entendre un certain nombre de
responsables qui ont réfléchi à ces
choses monsieur michel poniatowski donc
par les mesures y terrain a déclaré
aujourd'hui parler de haute cour pour la
faire de braille
c'est une galéjade mal fourbi inventées
et fabriquées après trois années et
c'est le plus récent des combats
électoraux
il est une resserrement mensongers
d'anciens ministres d'état réaffirment
qu'il n'a jamais été informé au
préalable en aucune manière et sous
aucune forme
la projet d'assassinât concernant le
député jean de ce genre le caennais
était aujourd'hui l'invité de nos
confrères de l'émission club de la
presse en europe numéro un
interrogé sur d'affaires de breuil
messieurs le canoë à d'abord rappelé
qu'ils n'étaient plus à l'époque où est
ce produit de garde des sceaux et qu'il
défiait quelconque de trouver son nom
mêlé à une quelconque affaire à une
question du socialiste claude estier
messieurs le cannet vous allez
l'entendre dans une seconde a répondu
sur l'attitude prises à l'époque par
monsieur michel poniatowski
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
déclarations faites par monsieur
poniatowski le 29 décembre 1976
déclarant l'instruction close alors
instruction n'est pas close lorsqu'elle
est au stade uniquement de l'information
par la police refuse bien entendu la
police judiciaire s'est bien passé de
louvergny a dit est le commencement
d'une affaire par conséquent il
appartient au juge d'instruction puis au
tribunal saisi d'établir la vérité sur
la sphère qui lui est soumise par le
garde des sceaux actuelle a fait une
déclaration
si je ne me trompe au cours de la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler pour
annoncer que la justice si elle décide à
travers la chambre des mises en
accusation peut prolonger développer son
instruction
et puis il y aura un procès il y aura
des témoins il y aura débat
par conséquent toute la clarté sera fait
sur ce triste événement qu'a constitué
l'assassinât de monsieur wiley un mot de
nos prochaines émissions demain l'invité
d'honneur d'antenne 2010
roger paul dijoud ministre des dom tom
comme l'ont dit les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer et qui vient de
rentrer à paris après un séjour aux
antilles et demain soir à 20h35 question
de temps l'émission de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 présenté par u berio et qui
a pour thème le temps de vivre
comment peut-on aménager le temps de
travail notamment celui les ouvriers
dans les usines qui répète à longueur de
journée quelques fois sur les chaînes de
montage des mêmes gestes des centaines
et des centaines de fois comment
aménager ce temps leur temps pour leur
permettre d'avoir le temps de vivre
demain donc
abbas of france and sport paris-roubaix
cycliste permis à l'italien moser
d'accomplir un exploit remporté pour la
troisième fois consécutive la course
égalant la piste
la classique de nos confrères l'équipe
et le parisien libéré a été très
mouvementée les français se sont très
bien comportés du plat salé deuxième et
hino obtient son meilleur résultat dans
cette épreuve
il est 4e voici le final
même sans l'appui paris roubaix reste
une course dure est belle ou comme
d'habitude les meilleurs coureurs se
retrouvent en tête sur les pavés mais la
sélection se fait d'ailleurs sur les
pavés le français gilbert duclos
lassalle est tombée une mésaventure qui
est arrivée également aux champions du
monde race et au belge paul entier et de
vlaeminck
après cette chute du français quelques
kilomètres plus loin
francesco moser se retrouvait donc seule
au commandement après avoir réussi à
lâcher l'allemand cural mais derrière
lui duclos-lassalle revenait à tous
palme seulement le français était
victime d'une crevaison
un nouveau coup du sort qui anéantissait
tous ses espoirs
moser avait donc courses se gagnent avec
une force impressionnant dans un style
superbe l'italien arrivait à rouler avec
une minute 48 solide avance sur gilbert
duclos-lassalle deuxième de l'épaule
l'allemand tueur a offert l'une est
troisième à 3 minutes 30
quant à bernard hinault il s'adjugeait
la 4e place en battant postés
les belges de meyer de wolf et willems
mais à six minutes sun secondes du
vainqueur paris roubaix a tenu ses
promesses grâce notamment à francesco
moser un très grand champion et aux
français du taux la salle qui pourrait
bien gagner une classique peut-être la
flèche wallonne ou liège bastogne liège
qui auront lieu mercredi prochain
c'est ce qu'on lui souhaite tiercé le
prix de la télévision corée à longchamp
a été gagné par le cheval qui porte le
poids le plus lourd le glace mais -
glenn rome entraîné par smaga est monté
paranal que devant le cep de favori
norwegian et le 15e need you diomède
gagne à lyon
voici la dernière ligne droite sans
image au départ cela une speed qui a
mené mais dans la partie la plus abrupte
de la descente on a vu passer en tête
azur et or qui va mener maintenant
pendant longtemps la fin de la descente
le dernier tournant la ligne droite
derguy reniant kazakh rond c'est presque
noir et rouge rené duhaut est très bien
également il s'agit de poulains et
pouliches de 3 ans dont la valeur n'est
pas encore bien fixée mais en fait c'est
le meilleur qui va gagner
celui à qui le handicapeur effet pour
faire le plus gros poids à la corde
blanc et vert azur et or mène toujours
mais voici que need you le décramponne
en pleine piste kazakh à damier le set
par oui john attaqué va passer mais il
est attaqué à son tour par l'as de méroé
des neurones qui va remporter dans un
style créé sur sa deuxième victoire en
moins
moi c'est sur moi pour un avenir alors
oui le jeune garde la deuxième place et
la courageuse un idiot l'une des rares
remettre du lot à ce 3e as 7 et 15 à
l'arrivée avec les rapports qui vont
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour 5 francs
dans l'ordre 5660 et dans un ordre
différent
1132 le 4e festival de bourges va se
terminer ce soir il a duré une semaine
et il a connu un grand succès c'est le
seul festival consacré en france
uniquement à la chanson 300 artistes des
musiciens plus de 40 spectacles et 40
mille entrées vous voyez un grand succès
le festival de bourges c'est tout à la
fois la présence d'artistes confirmés et
connu guy bedos catherine sauvage
mouloudji francis lemarque d'autres
encore est une sorte de viviers pour
ceux qui aiment aller à la recherche de
nouveaux talents
la mini compagnie
avec son orgue de barbarie naphtaline
peut déjà être considéré comme une des
révélations de ce printemps de bourges
un printemps qui après lavilliers
higelin ou renault propose cette année
de nouveaux talents à des milliers de
jeunes affamés de musique entassés sous
les chapiteaux dans cette tour de babel
de la chanson où tous les genres sont à
dire les points communs quelquefois il y
en a comme dans le cas de maxime le
forestier grimaud l'oil que nous avons
marié le premier jour sur la scène si je
puis dire
quelquefois il y en a pas du tout c'est
à dire qu'on peut aussi bien présenter
des gens comme mouloudji francis
lemarque et comme ce soir le groupe
trust 12° 5
bon
jeudi
là
j'aime bien la musique des promenades
musicales savez bien te bénisse et je
reprends du disp en disco les mangas je
suis venu pour ça et j'étais là pour les
quatre jours de pâques et lancera les
termes ça pose un problème pour
l'instant vient d'arriver au pouvoir
c'est moi de fabien autant je doive pas
quoi avoir de regrets
je suis donc si on va aller voir du rock
avoir deux ans qu'on a de l'argent pour
aller voir deux trucs
rien
non
m
bis est pour rien que j'ai pu je me suis
dérangé la vie il faut maintenant faut
que je penche plus pour que c'est une
passe d envie
moyens 2-2 fin
pas moyen de changer trop fort cette
fois il n'y a plus rien à faire
il sent la rose qui se pointent tous par
loi
et si j'y mets du sentiment c'est plus
de la même façon qu'avant j'avais plus
pour passer le temps plus lent mais rien
n'est pas pareil movinand c'est pas
pareil m'est arrivé des mets juste pour
passer le temps
seul nuage dans ce printemps de voûte le
problème financier car comme la plupart
des festivals le festival de bourges
reste déficitaire
et si cette année on espère ramener son
déficit de 56 à 40 l'usure cela reste
quand même très loin de la misère à coup
sûr qu'ils le font mais en retrait de
son soutien et lui consacre la moitié de
son petit budget alors maintenant à
mousse
on attend que d'autres vont soutenir cet
effort qui seule permettra de ne pas
remettre en question la préparation du
5e festival
météo pour demain bien sûr les régions
est ardenne bourgogne alsace jura alpes
il soufflera un vent de sud est et le
temps sera ensoleillé et chaud surtout
la panique alors sur ouest bretagne
vendée un ciel variable prédominera les
températures baisseront et les vents
tourneront au nord ouest et entre ces
deux zones nuages avec des pluies et des
orages localement sur l'auvergne et les
cévennes loyer votants gerald mais ça se
gâte un peu tout de même
lagence pour les économies d'énergie
vous recommande de mettre à l'arrêt vos
installations de chauffage toutefois les
températures restant fraîches dans le
limousin l'aveyron le massif central le
jura en provence et en corse en dessous
dessus de 350 m vous pouvez là bas si
vous y habitez maintenir l'alluré
actuelle de votre chauffage
le dernier journal vous sera présenté
peu avant 23h par gérard holtz
n'oubliez pas demain antenne 2010
présenté par patrick lecocq avec comme
invité d'honneur monsieur paul dijoud
bonsoir merci